Get
much news
is probably what Hall
Vincy and within him do wrong ways
from him it is him the way to get
this
oh we're all we raise a
watermelon. And when we cool. We call
him and he. Almost
Bush. Ever go to town with our little
girl says.
Yes
Is Us on the rise in rain we can go to
to become a mother when the little girl and she wasn't going to quit.
We walked into it and we do no more on the way to get there but what else
mom walked us
there.
Were on their feet all came the bill.
I got married in the. I mean in y'all can and you
know when I came to
Bill. I am have been playing a little for
this
city has gone along doing you sure nothing about it. Yeah
I got a friend from a loving.
Boney in the office and he's Mambo all in a nothing
between me mock or call God low.
They're probably lower my phone and he laughed his most.
Whoever they put
up with.
Our marks on he's in uses he been our Muses even sell.
Oh we can all see.
Now you say in youth is.
Us again. Then I real the rare phone haven't you before
I moved up in the process.
I live on Crown eleven you perform live in the
process now they will appear in the prize twenty five
eighteen homeroom
you
know we're going real. M.R. I'm on how your. I with
them home Tuesday.
And we say also.